you never forget the one who steals your
heart
or the one
who kicks your ass some fishy [ __ ] is
happening on our Beach and my balls say
we need to go over there and check it
out
does it badly damage we're lifeguards my
balls say just take it he's right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies Baywatch works because we follow
rules
this is a train wreck
I met Brody and not a single [ __ ] was
given is where the best formers in the
whole world it's like if a human [ __ ]
a jetski which is impossible but be so
cool there's a cop
don't jack off on my sheets just
remember I'm always watching beyond
matters
[Music]
All Things Considered things going to
get a lot worse that's good luck we need
to search the morgue for evidence
check his cane for needle marks I'm
gonna check his taint lift his [ __ ]
scrotum and check his taint
dude it's a taint man it's a taint and
even look get closer
oh holy yoghurt oh there's a hole that's
just his boat a little smile most of
that do not post that just a head full
of ball sack he turned four nails into
the goddamn X Games that's cuz we were
in lifeguard pursuit oh okay
except for this no [ __ ] such thing as
lifeguard
[Music]
you